my review about it is this sucks people
die too soon
there was no build up he just died wrong
with you his head fell off season finale
that's all no do not reference Game of
Thrones here ever
[Music]
all right check out this house right
here this is known as the world's
loneliest house
so wow I mean does Amazon deliver there
did you do that what did you do that on
canva no is that air
no this is like um so people discovered
this house and they for a long time
didn't know like what the story was yo
that looks like that scene is Star Wars
at the end you know when they're in that
clip just for scale look at that
freaking Island that's where that house
is where's that Island though scene's
hiding there Michael Jackson's there
he's still alive Tupac's there
everybody's there yeah that's just
hanging out small house they're having
their own like real world like their own
show that they have it's in Iceland in
twisting what do you guys think that was
built for like and why and who's there a
prison
a prison mmm damn I think it's the
world's biggest introvert and they're
just like I'm sick of looking people
they keep saying it to themselves Zoom
it hold on and how do you and and like
groceries like that's what I'm saying
how does that work fish right fish so I
guess nobody's living there right now
but they do like it's their summer house
Airbnb was a thing wow so there used to
be somebody living there but like what
why do you think it got built like a
lighthouse there was no Lighthouse this
is just this I don't know someone
committed a crime Little Island Rock I
believe somebody does own it but
um you know what's weird they don't
maybe they don't own it someone has to
own that so is there anything that any
backstores would you do yeah yes there
is so people were thinking that it would
like this for a long time people thought
it was a rich dude that built it as a
Escape in case it was like a zombie
apocalypse oh all right that that was
like the most believed thing I believe
in that but
um it turns out the real reason it's
there is something super not that crazy
at all
um basically these do you guys here I'll
actually show you a picture was it
because a lady had too many kids and
she's like I need a break
yeah women right
look how far she went
jeez these loud ass babies here's a clue
you know what these are
Penguins puffins puffins yeah what these
are cute right so um it's a house for
them yeah it'll wait in a way it is for
them it's a house for them oh is it to
study them not quite Puffin serving
muffins in the crib is that what he ate
kind of so this house was built in the
1950s it's a puffin recipe as just like
a place to sleep while these Puffin
Hunters were killing puffins why would
they hunt the puffins for
maybe they were hungry
yeah they would come to that area all
the time and they would hunt and I guess
it's because hunting puffins is actually
you can't do that other than in that
area so they built a house so they would
go there just so it's like a hunting
lodge yeah but for puffins yeah and they
would do only that
or like what are they are they selling
them yeah what's maybe they smoke them
so they can puff maybe that's a thing
that they eat out there see what you did
there that's just too cute of an animal
to eat though it doesn't say that they
actually did anything with them they
might have just been it might have been
a sport baby oh like a target shooting a
weird little like Duck Hunt like yeah
exactly it's like duck hunt with puffins
yeah but it's super sad that that's the
reason they built this little house I
mean that looks like such a nice place
that little house is filled which is
ammunition guns and like artillery and
[__] oh but it says just dead puffins
everywhere yeah and it said that
nobody's lived there since like I'm
almost uh almost 100 years so it
answered our question it's like what do
they eat muffin oh but it even it even
says that 300 years ago that Island had
five families living on it five it does
look it does look a little big like the
house is very small yeah it's pretty
small right nice sliding Hill that's
like sledding I mean it looks bigger
than a cul-de-sac but can you can you
imagine the island fever that you'd get
it's just five families you see the same
maybe it was really just one family and
became five families but like hamsters
because when you imagine like being on
an island you imagine being able to see
360 off of yeah it's only one side yeah
it's like literally you see one picture
it's like standing in the Hollywood Bowl
as a conductor just staring out into the
crowd you think they're like old school
Vikings and they just they could have
just traveled a little bit farther to
find the land and then they found this
island they're like that's it we found
something [__] it Christopher Columbus
that is true like as an Explorer you
never know when that's the last land
you're gonna find so that's that concept
is crazy to me nuts nuts that people are
just like we're going this way and we
have absolutely no clue I want to go
back in time and do that
but what's west of Westeros
no I'm the only [__] nerd here what
the [__] where's that for Arya Stark
Game of Throne or people say I look like
Arya Stark I can see it in the eyes but
I can also see nothing in their eyes
about this [__] topic I knew
I knew thank you my first camera's in
the way my first time has a guest on
this show like years ago uh like my very
first episode when I was sitting here
right where she's at you guys all talked
about Game of Thrones and I'd never seen
it and I just sat here dead silent the
whole episode and I was like Oh I
thought you were gonna say that you're
just lying just like impossible no I
didn't even try because you guys are so
enthusiastic because it was like new and
it was current and they had the chair
and everything and they were all excited
I was just like oh okay were you sitting
here like look at this bunch of nerds I
was like stupid bunches
wait is Joe the only person who watched
Game of Thrones yep yeah
you haven't watched in the pilot oh
y'all see it you haven't seen it I tried
and it just didn't catch me don't talk
to me right you haven't seen it I
haven't seen this you know are you
watching House of dragons yeah the whole
season was over remember something that
would make you mad I did watch one
episode I picked one at random I was
like let me give this a shot you can't
do that you got to do it from the
beginning what the [__] is wrong with
you dog for sure look at that wait let
me see what this is about who does that
[__] picked an episode it ended up being
the one where Ned dies
[Applause]
and I was like oh this guy died must not
be important
yeah the [__] is wrong with you you got
it bro
my review about it is
this sucks people die too soon
there was no build up he just died wrong
with you his head fell off season finale
that's all no do not reference Game of
Thrones here ever it turns you can you
just with the wrong group
and why are you writing on your phone
hey first of all calm down all right she
was trying to [__] make the screen
bigger like this
[Laughter]
I can't because you guys are all pretty
like jet stating gypsies what I used to
be I guess oh you don't travel a lot no
more no I feel like dancers are just in
a different continent every day there
was Wi-Fi everywhere we went I think
it's like Comforts like that I don't
want to live without flexible toilets
and Wi-Fi why what if it's an island but
you got all the things that you need
Wi-Fi Amazon you don't have a single
person with you though it's just
yourself it's like this but can you get
deliveries huh ubereats yeah you get
yeah I I want to live on Ireland just to
be naked on the island yes you can do
that now just yeah but Jordan Island
Vibes is like you know that's more you
can be like naked Nick wait but like
what's the alternative it's like so
we're just gonna be on an island by
ourselves with everything normal so you
just just loneliness you just won't have
another person around you yeah yeah so
everything the it is but just be super
lonely it's like covid lockdown you know
what I mean like but you're on an island
you would want that you think I'm
vacation yourself I want to try it
what's the max you could do it for then
all right 10 minutes that was like that
show alone on Netflix alone alone yeah I
love alone and they still haven't even
reached and nobody's done in 90 days
they have on the other Seasons you got
to watch it on uh the History Channel oh
really all nine Seasons or whatever the
[__] it's [__] good oh alone's so
good during lockdown I did for 30 days
what do you mean I came back from Europe
nobody want to touch me because I was
tainted you didn't see one other person
for 30 days no I I was at the house and
then the only interaction I had was like
live streaming talking on the phone if
it was during lockdown it don't count
because we're all doing that then two
people came to my house to talk to me
through the screen were they Jehovah's
Witness
one was my friend he dropped me off a
cheesecake oh yeah he tells that I guess
it's different when there's a
camaraderie the whole freaking nation is
also locking down yeah but if you're
there with your Wi-Fi and you're
watching the whole world hang out with
each other and doing other [__] and
you're by yourself it's gonna be kind of
lonely yeah that's more lonely if you
know everyone else is doing but if it
was lockdown and you were on that island
say this oh that'd be a nice spot to be
locked down especially if like everyone
else's lockdown might as well be there I
think if it was a super deadly virus too
that would work yeah yeah that wouldn't
be bad do you sometimes feel though that
like if you're not in a tropical island
it's not quite a real Island a little
bit like sometimes they have islands
like here Iceland and then they have
them around like Washington and in the
north yeah and then you see like
Christmas trees and [__] and you're like
that's not an island bro like
dude that's funny to be going up to this
place that ain't no Island you're not a
real Islander what the [__] is that
what are you talking about
yeah because what do you think of
stereotypical Island it is
right that's what I think of actually
yeah
swimming and clear blue
Castaways you know but this looks crazy
because there's not even another Tree on
there there's it's a boring Island it is
yeah and all you do is is you imagine
mowing that lawn yeah and you had to do
that you got to go up why are you even
why
how would you even because the
neighboring Island's gonna talk [__] it
does that it looks like they mow that
they do it good it looks like a nice
clean shaved that's crazy
yeah it's not it's not Tall Grass you
know can you imagine like they have to
ship over building materials and set
that thing up though yeah that's wild
and is there a toilet there because like
they don't got it's probably a commode
it's probably not a toilet toilet it's
probably just a hole in the ground yeah
do you think you can live like your
grandparents I can't I don't think I can
my grandparents live pretty good but
maybe my great grandparents
my grandparents were Rich As [__] my
grandma was balling dude oh yeah yeah
cause my great grandpa's an executive
for Toshiba so she [__] lived good
yeah yeah he didn't get any like
inheritance
[__] dumbass [__] divorce her
husband and [__] left the whole
family and [__] and wanted to be
Christian god dude they kicked their ass
out they're like if you don't stay
[__] Buddhist you [__] Westerner
get the [__] out of here damn they just
yeah and they built another house so she
they kicked her out of their house and
they built another house and said you
live here so she sacrificed all that to
be a Christian that's one of the things
damn yeah a couple of other things too
you didn't even inherit that nope you
didn't even hear it her love for God
yeah yeah
her
very well yeah her sister married really
well oh that's good yeah yeah yeah and
they're like uh yeah
they're doing well in Europe they have a
Plastics Company out there I'm glad it
all turned out okay
I don't get none of that God there's a
happy ending to that
[Music]
foreign